[Applause]
Rogue Traders daring explorers who
benefit from a unique style of Freedom
normally unheard of in the Imperium with
means to decide the fate of entire
regions of space little can stop them in
their pursuit of domination and power
and they do not Venture alone their crew
contains some of the Galaxy's most
unique denizens and sanctioned psychers
strange xenos Servants of the
Inquisition
and even Space Marines of the adeptice
Estates
ulfa is a lone space Wolf Survivor whose
pack was defeated by the murderous
drukari
[Music]
all of them are ready to follow you on
the battlefield where they skills can be
the deciding factor between Victory and
defeat
but the Rogue Traders true might lies in
their personal void ship and the
resource Rich worlds under their control
this is what makes them such dominant
figures
even still the enemies of humanity are
numerous
and they will not relinquish an
opportunity to strike
a ghastly Peril lurks an Insidious
corruption which works to undermine the
strength of the imperium's most staunch
Defenders chaos
only with uncompromising Zeal and
steadfast Faith Can Rogue Traders
withstand the lore of the ruinous powers
and those who succumb to the darkness
the calamitous fit in exchange for their
soul only Madness and amnition the wind